We're here in central Hokkaido, thanks to Odigo,...
...visiting an ice village supposedly built out on a frozen lake in the mountains.
This whole place is free.
They just spend their time building all this stuff and they don't get much, I guess.
So, yeah.
Yeah!
It's nice to donate.
They did a really good job here.
This building is made entirely of ice...
...and includes a cafe, a small second floor for seating,...
...and a stage for performances!
You can even get drinks in glasses made of ice, which was really cool to drink out of.
They let you take the glass home as well,...
...but good luck getting it back to your fridge!
So, this place was super cool.
This ice cafe is definitely the coolest part.
I'm impressed that they could make something this big out of ice.
But anyway, it is cold!
Remember this is all ice and snow.